[موسيقى]
درس من اربع سنوات
فجاه اجا صار زلزال الساعه ثلاثه ثلاثه
ونصف اربعه بالضبط ما بعرف
انهدت البناي الجرح واحد من عندي من
الاولاد
الجرحى معبينا شوارع الشهداء المشافعت
دمارك كتير بنايات لبينا نداء انه في مخيم
ايواء لانه اخواننا المضرين كثيرين وعم
نعمل بقدر الله عليه وسبحان الله انه الجو
برد مع كل هالبرد لبينا نداء واخواننا انا
نازح بحس
راح بيته عنده ماوى يعني لله الامر الحمد
لله وين هلا عم نسمع يعني نلبي اخواتنا ان
شاء الله وبتمنى من كل واحد يعني قادر على
العمل يعني يذهب بشكل تطوعي
ويساعد اخواتنا
خارجون من ركام الزلزال
انقاذ طفله من حضن اختها التي فارقت
الحياه
اخراج طفله من انقاض منزلها بعد 24 ساعه
من الزلزال الله اكبر
رضيع ينجو من انهيار منزله
صبي يخرج حيا بعد ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال
ما شاء الله
انقاذ طفله ووالدها بعد 100 ساعه من
الزلزال
العثور على ناجيه قضت خمسه ايام تحت
الانقاض
انقاذ طفله بعد 150 ساعه من الزلزال
[موسيقى]
معنى مشاهدينا من ريف حلب الصحافه احمد
ابو لؤي استاذ احمد يعني تداعيات هذه
الازمه
تتفاقم خصوصا انسانيا وخصوصا في المنطقه
الشماليه من سوريا كيف هو الوضع من هناك
هل هناك من مساعدات اضافيه ما المتوقع
بالساعات المقبله وما الواقع الان
نعم تحياتي عزيزتي يعني في الواقع يعني
اوضاع ماساويه بالعموم فبعد مرور ثمانيه
ايام على كارثه الزلزال
وانتهاء عملي واعلان فرقه الدفاع المدني
بانتهاء عمليات البحث وانقاذ العالقين بعد
فقدان الامن
بدخول اي نوع من انواع المساعدات
اضافه يعني بدء عمليات البحث والانتشار
بعد ما شبه انعدام لوجود احياء طبعا
بالنسبه
للمساعدات عزيزتي ما زال يدخل يعني حتى
اليوم مساعدات يعني
دخل اليوم من مناطق دير الزور ومناطق قوات
سوريا الديمقرا الديمقراطيه قافله مساعدات
محتويه على الوقود
والنواد الغذائيه
النظافه طبعا سانتقل للوضع الكارثي يعني
الوضع العائلات هنالك الاف الابنيه التي
تصدعت طبعا الاوضاع الكارثيه ما زالت
تزداد اعلاف العائلات تحت اغصان الزيتون
في مراكز لواء مؤقته ومنهم شيخيان تم نصها
من اجل ايواءهم في العراء ومنهم من ذهب
الى اقربائهم
يعني المقيمين في احواش عربيه او
منازل التي تعتبر اقل عرضه للسفر بسبب
الهزات الارتداديه التي تضرب بين الساعه
والاخرى مناطق شمال الغربي سوريا بما فيها
شمال حلب ومناطق ريف ادلب
طبعا كما ذكرت مساعدات اليوم دخل من
تحت اسم فزعه العشائر مناطق دير الزور
ويوم امس او قبل عن مساعدات داخليه يعني
عن التكافل
الذي يحصل عاده بين الاهالي السوريين وبين
المواطنين السوري هذا حدث انا عن مساعدات
خارجيه يعني كنا نرصد بالسعاده الماضيه لم
يصل اي شيء جديد حتى على المعابر
بالنسبه للمساعدات الداخليه بكل وضوح يعني
من اليوم الاول هنالك اهالي هنائي لم
يتضرروا هنالك مجموع مجموعات فرديه تعا
ولم تبرعات يعني بذلك من اجل اغاثه
المتضررين في الزلزال يعني وحتى يومنا هذا
يقومون بمساعدتهم والسعي لهم جاهدين من
اجل اغاثتهم وخاصه يعني في الاحوال الطقس
البارده اليوم احوال الطقس نجدها تحت
السفر
يعني اثنين او ثلاثه درجات يعني اوضاع
ماساويه
واليوم يجب على المنظمات الدوليه الدول
التي اضافه الى الدول التي تعدت باغاثه
السوريين يعني انقاذهم بشتى ليس فقط
بحافلات غذائيه وغيرها هذا كله مؤقت لازم
اليوم الشعبي مشاريع يعني اعمار شقق سكنيه
يعني لو الشقه تحتوي على غرفه او منتفع
ادنى شيء افضل من العيش بداخل الخيمه لا
تقيهم من برد الشتاء ولا حر الصيف يعني
المطلوب الاساسي هو حمله اعاده اعمار ولو
بسيطه وبامكانات بسيطه لكي لا تتفاقم
الازمه الانسانيه هناك خصوصا وان هذه
المنطقه اصلا هي تعاني من ازمه انسانيه
وكارثه انسانيه حقيقيه قبل هذا الزلزال
شكرا لك احمد ابو لؤي حدثتنا من ريف حلب
وينضم الينا ايضا الصحافه في شبكه نهر
ميديا عهد الصليبي من اورفا التركيه استاذ
عهد يعني ايضا
بالموضوع السوري سابدا به بما ان كنا
نتحدث هناك التعاضد الاجتماعي اليوم وهذه
العصبيه الداخليه التي شاهدناها والتي هي
يعني شيء طبيعي بالنظر لحجم الكارثه
الانسانيه لا تخفي ازمه حقيقيه ايضا هي
الازمه الانسانيه السياسيه ان كان بموضوع
المعابر وان كان بموضوع توزيع المساعدات
التي تصل الى دمشق ما هو الواقع فيها
مساء الخير والساده المشاهدين نعم مناطق
الجنوب التركي شهدت شهدته مناطق الشمال
السوري من فزعات يعني داخليه ويعني ايتار
ما بين العوائل والاخرى هناك الكثير من
المناطق تضررت بشكل كامل وفتحت مناطق اخرى
اكثر امانا المقارنه بالاحياء بالمناطق
والمدن التي شهدت وتضررت بشكل كبير من
الزلزال نزحت هذه العائلات من المناطق
المتضرره الى مناطق اخرى كان باستقبالهم
اذا تحدثنا عن الجانب السوري كان
باستقبالهم يعني ذويهم في مناطق اخرى اذا
تحدثنا عن مدينه اورفا فنزح الكثير من
اهالي الاحياء الوسطى الى المناطق الريفيه
اذا تحدثنا يعني لو ذكرنا مثلا منطقه اخشى
قلعه او تل ابيض التركي منطقه فيران شهير
ويعني سروج والمناطق الاخرى المحيطه بها
كذلك الامر في غازي عنتاب نزح الناس الى
المناطق المتطرفه والتي لا تحتوي اي من
المباني الطابقيه التي قد تكون هي يعني
مهد والسقوط اذا حدثت هناك زلزال او هزات
اقتداديه تكون قويه او متوسطه القوه انا
كنت يعني في مدينه انطاكيا واقابله معكم
الاحداث هناك لحظه بلحظه خرجت منها فجر
اليوم المنطقه مدمره بشكل كامل من قام
يعني باجلاء هؤلاء الناس الذين نجوا من
هذه الماساه هي بعض المنظمات يعني السوريه
اتحدث عن السوريه هنا فقط هي بعض المنظمات
السوريه وكان هناك تقصير من المنظمات اخرى
دخلت بشكل متاخر كما يعني كما دخلت على
المنطقه يعني بحسب الارقام التقديريه
الرسميه التركيه هناك اكثر من 1.5 مليون
شخص اليوم لجاوا الى الخيام بعد هذه
الكارثه طبعا هي ارقام تقديريه هل لديك
رقم تقريبي عن السوريين الذين اصلا كانوا
يقطنون في هذه المناطق واليوم يجعوا الى
الخيم
سيدتي منطقه انطاكيا مدينه انطاكيا وحدها
كان تحتوي ما يقارب 200 الى 300 مواطن
سوري وجميعهم هجروا من هذه المنطقه جراء
هذا الزلزال هناك بعض الخيام مبنيه داخل
المدينه يعني التي هي شهدت هذا الدمار لكن
هذه القيام هي خيام مرحليه ان صح التعبير
يعني موجوده في منطقه حديقه السوريين
وحديقه اتاتورك فقط في هذه المدينه كذلك
الامر في مدينه شارلي اورفا ببعض الحدائق
بنيت هذه القيم وايضا اذا ذكرنا ان الذين
سكنوا في هذه القيام هم دول لهم من
السوريين يعني الاتراك لديهم يعني منازل
في مناطق يعني ربما مدن واخرى يعني في
مناطق اخرى لم تشهد هذه المناطق اي اثار
او تضرر من الزلزال جل الساكنين القاطعين
في القيام هم السوريين وما زلنا الان نبحث
عن قيام
لنبنيها ونخرج الاهالي الذين ما زالوا
متمسكين في منازلهم التي تصدعت جراء هذا
الزلزال ربما لو اتيحت لنا الفرصه ويعني
وتوفرت هذه القيام سترتفع النسبه الى اكثر
من ذلك من هذه الاحصاء التي قيلت بانها
مليون ونصف اعتقد انها سترتفع الى اكثر من
ذلك بكثير وربما حتى تصل الى الضعف الان
بعض الجهات تحاول ان يعني توفر هذا هذه
الخدمات لكن الماسات اكبر من ذلك بكثير
المنظمات غير مستعده لمثل هذه الكوارث هذا
ما اظهرته يعني الايام القليله الماضيه
منطقه انطاكيا منطقه غازي عنتاب منطقه
شارلي اوروبا وكذلك ماردين وادي هذه
المناطق يعني ماردين الوحيده التي لم تشهد
اي تضرر من الزلزال هي اصبحت يعني محط
يعني قدم او ملجا لكثير من السوريين هذه
المناطق تحتوي يعني 90% او 80% من السوريه
المتواجدين بتركيا والذين قدرت احصائيه
عام 2022 بانهم ثلاث ملايين الف الاتراك
كذلك الامر كان لهم يعني نصيب كبير من هذا
الزلزال لكن ماساه السوريين كانت اكثر
مع العلم يعني ان يعني بدستور عمل هذه
المنظمات يجب ان يكون هناك خطه طوارئ
جاهزه للتعامل مع الكوارث الطبيعيه نحن لا
نتحدث عن كارثه من صنع الانسان نحن نتحدث
عن كارثه طبيعيه يجب ان على هذه المنظمات
ان تكون جاهزه للتعامل مع يعني سانتقل
بالسؤال الى شق اخر اليوم التقديرات
الرسميه لعدد الضحايا ممكن ان يرتفع الى
50,000 وممكن اكثر بحسب اخر يعني تصاريح
المع
المنظمات الدوليه هل لديك اي عدد تقريبي
عن السوريين الذين قضوا بهذا الزلزال
والمفقودين حتى الساعه
يعني بالنسبه لاحصائيه التي اعلن عنها
وتحديدا في الجنوب التركي ربما في الشمال
السوري يعني توضحت الاعداد لكون الذين
قتلهم من ابناء المناطق نفسها وتبينت يعني
جثثهم وانتهت عمليات بشكل كامل ويعني
اخرجت جميع الجثث بنسبه كبيره ليست بشكل
تام لكن في الجنوب التركي لم تخرج جميع
الجسد وهناك العشرات بعد ان قمنا بجرد
يعني عمل احصائيه
للسوريه المفقودين جرائد الزلزال هناك
لدينا المئات من العائلات ما تزال هي
مفقوده ما بين يعني مصاب نقل الى مشفى
ويعني ضاعت اخباره او انقطعت اخباره والان
ما نزال من خلال هذا الفريق الذي شكلناه
خلال يعني ايام الزلزال فريق بدائي ويعني
كان اشبه باستجابه طارئه لهذه الاحداث
استطعنا من اخراج الكثير يعني من الكثير
من الضحايا وربما العالقين تحت الانقاض
الاعداد اكثر من ذلك بكثير انا غادرت
منطقه اعطاك حجر اليوم ويعني تركنا الكثير
من الناس ما يزالون تحت الانقاض غادرنا
حقيقه المرغمين نحن على على هذا
التصرف علما ان هناك قبل
ثلاث ساعات من الان اخرجت فتاه ما تزال
على قيد الحياه السوريه من منطقه
بالقرب من الجامعه الفاتح في منطقه كما
يزال احياء عالقون تحت الانقاظ لكن
الاعلان الرسمي عن انتهاء هذه العمليه
ويعني
بدايه العمل في قانون الطوارئ اجبرنا على
الخروج من هذه المنطقه وتركين تحت الانقاض
الاعداد اكثر من ذلك بكثير والاعداد التي
وقعنا عنها بتصوري انها اعلنت عدد الوصول
الى المستشفى
واثبات وجود هذه الجثه امام تحت الانقاض
فاعدادهم كبيره كبيره جدا واعتقد ان
الاحصائيه ستتحدث بشكل اني ربما تشهد هذه
الاحصائيه التحديث لعده اشهر شكرا لك
عهد للصيبه حدثتنا من ارفا التركيه
[موسيقى]
خيام تنصب من جديد نشهد يشبه بدايات
التغريبه السوريه
بعد ان اعتقدوا انهم استقروا في ملاجئهم
ان كانت مساكن او مخيمات هجرتهم الارض مره
اخرى
هنا ريف ادلب هي ذاتها الارض التي اهتزت
قبل اكثر من اسبوع تحت قاطينها لتدمر ما
بقي من منازل بكل قسوتها تستقبل الذين
نزحوا مرتين او ربما اكثر
بعضهم وصفوا الكارثه التي ضربتهم بالرعب
الذي يفوق رعب الحرب صار عمري 36 سنه
اكلنا طيران وغزاير وبرابيل وما خفنا مثل
هالخوفي هاي الرابعه بتاريخ حياته صار ما
ما شفت من اكبر من هالرعبه هاي كان نايمين
الساعه تتربى
هذه الارضيه قويه والله
وما حسيت غير تحت الدردين
بالضبط يعني
ساعدتهم شحيحه وطرقات مغلقه واجراءات
مطوله كلما تاخرت كلما زادت معاناه نازح
الزلزال
ليكونوا الضحيه وهم فرق واغاثه النفس في
الوقت ذاته عن احد المطوعين في بلده كلا
[موسيقى]
غزال لحدث والدمار اللي ساوى بها البيوت
بعض من المنظمات المحليه تحاول بما تملك
من امكانيات بسيطه ان تمد يد العون سواء
بتامين الخيام والقليل من القوه البشريه
العامله او بمعونات بسيطه قامت منظمه
المراكز الهواء في مناطق ارمناز ومعرض
نصرين وجنديرس بالاضافه الى الاتارب
والتوامه وحارم
نزوح او لجوء لعله قدر لا مهرب منه امام
شعب قضاء اخر عقد في التنقل واللجوء الى
اي مامن او ما ظنوا انه المامن الا ان
الارض نفسها لم تعد تحتمل معاناتهم
اذا عمر العربيه
من جنديرس مجددا مشاهدينا الصحافه محمد
لقشقر محمد يعني متابع معك طيله هذا
النهار رصد الواقع الاغاثي هناك في بلد
اصلا ما زال يعاني من تبعات الحرب المدمره
في سوريا ساسال بدايه عن موضوع المعابر هل
هناك اي تغيير بهذا الموضوع خصوصا ان كان
هناك تصريحات جديده من الجانب التركي
باستخدام الاجواء الجويه التركيه وبان
المعابر مفتوحه ما هي يعني صحه هذه
التصريحات
نعم في الحقيقه تدخل المساعدات يعني من
اغلب المعابر هنا في الشمال السوري نحن
نتحدث عن خمسه معابر على طول الحدود
السوريه التركيه في المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطره المعارضه معبر جرابلس ومعبر الراعي
وباب السلامه ومعبر حمام ومعظر باب الهوى
طبعا المعبر الوحيد الذي دخلت منه
المساعدات المقدمه من الامم المتحده ومعبر
باب الهواء الحدودي يعني حيث بلغت عدد
الشاحنات التي دخلت 62 شاحنه كان اخرها
اليوم عندما دخلت عشره شاحنات محمله
بالمولدات وبعض المساعدات الاغاثيه
الاغاثيه اما ان تحدثنا عن معبر حمام فهو
معبر تجاري بالاصل دخلت منه مساعدات
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
من مركز الملك سلمان عندما دخلت اليوم امس
احد عشر حافله ضمن القافله الاولى التي
انطلقت من مطار غازي عنتاب بعد وصول سته
طائرات الى هذا المطار يعني وتوجهت الى
الداخل السوري هناك بعض المساعدات النتيجه
الحملات الشعبيه حملات التبرعات يعني جمع
الاحتياجات في من خارج سوريا تدخل من بعض
المعابر الاخرى طبعا يعني بالاضافه
ليست موجوده هناك معابر الكل قادر على
ايصال المساعدات اذا اراد ايصال المساعدات
نعم نعم
من يريد ايصال اريد ان اؤكد هذه النقطه
هذه النقطه
المعابر موجوده لمن يريد ادخال المساعدات
الى شمال غرب سوريا هناك خمسه معابر جاهزه
لدخول المساعدات من عن طريق الاراضي
السوريه التركيه
محمد شكرا لك على كل حال سنتابع معك
التغطيه
النشرات الاخباريه الباقيه شكرا لك
الجدار الحدودي بين تركيا وسوريا لم يمنع
سكان الاخيره من رؤيه اختلاف التعامل مع
الكارثه بين البلدين ففي جهتهم سوريين
يشعرون بالخذلان منسيون من الانقاذ
والمساعدات العاشله
خذلان وتخلان وغضب مشاعر تختلط بالبرد
والفقد والدموع السوريون حملوا مجددا
اكياس الجثث التي اعتادوا حملها لسنوات
بعضهم حظي باقامه طقوس وداعا وان كانت
مختصره والبعض الاخر لا يزال بمرحله
انتظار خروجهم من تحت الانقاض
الحرقه لم تزل ببدايتها لكن الغضب عارم لم
يعتادوا البقاء في الصف الخلفي رغم اهمال
اوضاعهم لسنوات فصرخاتهم ليست لغطاء او
طعام رغم ضاله المساعدات التي وصلت الى
الشمال غرب سوريا وانعدامها ببعض المناطق
ما اريد اكل نريد ناكل التراب بس انحفظ
كرامتنا السوريون يصفونه بالتخلي
والنسيانه مع التماسهم لفروق كثيره في
التعامل المحلي والدولي مع جيرانهم
الاتراك شركائهم بالكارثه والدمار الكارثه
لم تقدر حدودا لكن الجدار بينهما حدد وحدد
خدمات كثيره من الانقاذ للاسعاف للماوى
فعلى الجهه الاخرى من الجدار الاف عمال
الانقاذ والالاف من المسعفين اضافه الى
معدات رفع ثقيله وجرافات وكلاب بوليسيه
تجب الشوارع صخب محركات تضغط عليه احيانا
صافره سيارات الاسعاف وزحام المساعدات لكن
في الجهه السوريه وقفت عمليات الانقاذ منذ
يومين صمت مستغرب تحتمه امكانات محدوده مع
تفوق الكارثه على قدرات الخوض البيضاء
نقاط التفتيش احبطت جهود الاغاثه الدوليه
والمساعده العاجله في الجزء الذي تسيطر
عليه الفصائل المدعومه من تركيا
والمساعدات المنتظره تعرقل دخولها لاكثر
من منطقه بسبب تقسيمات جغرافيه وانقسامات
سياسيه وولائيه
في سوريا مشاهدينا يصعب تحديد حجم الاضرار
الاقتصاديه التي اصابت البلاد مقارنه
بالجانب التركي وذلك بسبب الاوضاع
السياسيه المنقسمه ومعاناه البلاد من حرب
مستمره منذ اكثر من 12 عاما المزيد في
تقرير التالي
خسائر متزايده في الارواح والاملاك
والاقتصاد سببه الزلزال المدمر الذي اصاب
سوريا الاسبوع الماضي ليضيف معاناه اضافيه
لاقتصاد انهكته صراعات سياسيه لاكثر من 12
عاما وما زالت مستمره غياب البيانات
الرسميه والشفافيه واتساع رقعات تاثير
الزلزال بين مناطق خاضعه للنظام واخرى
للمعارضه يزيدان من صعوبه تقدير حجم
الاضرار والتي تجاوزت بالمجمل عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات
وحول الخسائر الماديه افادت منظمه الخوه
البيضاء بان اكثر من 300 وخمسه وسبعين
مبنى انهار كليا واكثر من 1200 مبنى انهار
جزئيا كما تصدعت الاف المباني الاخرى
كما اصاب زلزال اقتصاد سوريا في مقتل خاصه
انه ضرب اربعه محافظات مسؤوله عن اكثر من
ثلث اقتصاد البلاد
فمحافظه حلب المتاثره الاكبر من الزلزال
مسؤوله عن اكثر من 16% من اقتصاد سوريا
فيما تمثل محافظه حماه المرتبه الخامسه
بنسبه مساهمه في الاقتصاد السوري بما يصل
الى تسعه في المئه ثم اللاذقيه في المرتبه
السادسه بسبعه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه
مساهمه بالاقتصاد اما محافظه ادلب التي
تنقسم السيطره فيها بين النظام والمعارضه
والمتاثره بالزلزال تصل مساهمتها في
الاقتصاد الى 2.7
انقسام الوضع السياسي في سوريا يزيد من
معاناه متاثرين بالزلزال المدمر اعاده
الاعمار على الجانب السوري خاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع للمعارضه والتي في
الاصل تضم مئات الالاف من المهجرين ستكون
الاصعب في غياب رقابه حكوميه وهرب من
المسؤوليه من المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
شادي الزعيم العربيه
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره على الارض من اديمان
ينضم الينا محمود شكر موفد العربيه محمود
يعني كنا نرصد مع زملاء في المناطق الاخرى
مراكز اللجوء المخيمات كيف هي الصوره معك
من هناك ولكن اسمح لي ايضا ان ارحب من
غازي عنتاب مفرد العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي محمود كيف هي سوره مخيمات اللجوء
وايضا يعني مراكز الايواء هل هي كافيه لكل
الناجين من هذا الزلزال هناك
نعم اسمحي لي بدايه في الامر ان نستغل هذا
الموقع الذي نحن به وان نخرج ولو قليلا عن
قضيه مخيمات النزوح لنذهب مباشره الى غرفه
العمليات نعم انا في مركز في مخيم كبير في
ادمن وان في غرفه العمليات المركزيه
التابعه للبحث التونسيه والتي هي مربوطه
امامي مباشره على الشاشه بغرفه العمليات
المركزيه التابعه للامم المتحده في تركيا
والتابعه ايضا المربوطه مباشره لغرفه
العمليات في جنيف ساذهب مباشره الان ماذا
يجري على كل الاراضي التركيه وايضا على كل
المواقع التي نحن بها جنرال مباشره رقم
230 وال44 ماذا يعني
هو عدد المواقع البحث والتفتيش التي تم
فتحها منذ حدوث الزلزال في تركيا الى 203
اعداد اوكي هي هي مواقع الناشطه الان
النشيطه يعني الان هنالك 44 موقع يعمل به
في كل الاراضي التركيه نعم
موقع يعمل فيهم حاليا في تركيا جنرال 702
ما هو هذا الرقم 27 هو هما
من تحت الانقاذ من اللي فتح الموقع
المتحده وقمت بتركيز الموقع هذا الى هذه
اللحظه على 702 تم انتشار جنرال الرقم من
479 والرقم 207 ما هو 207 20
كامم متحده وككل فرق دوليه موجوده نعم كل
الفرق تشتغل تحت لواء الامم المتحده هي
خاف بانتشال الاعداد
407 ما هو عدد الموتى الذي تم انتشاله من
تحت الانقاذ من قبل الفرق تحت لو جنرال لو
نذهب الان بهذا التوقيت المباشر ماذا يجري
على كل الاراضي التركيه الان كم دوله
تشتغل الان كم فريق
الدوله شركه باعداد الفرق
144 فريق يشتغلوا على الاراضي التركيه
وفهم عشرين فريق اخرين عبروا على سعادتهم
قادمين لتعزيز المجهود هنا في تركيا اذا
ذهبت الى الصوره المباشره على الفرق التي
تعمل الان في كل الاراضي الان اريد
المدينه التي نحن بها
نعم كل فريق عنده ايديه عنده تعريف نتاعه
المتحده التعريف هذا يكون موجود على
الخريطه وبالتالي نعرفوا كل فريق دولي
ملتوي تحته المتحده وين موجود بالضبط
يشتغل منطقه اليمن ونحن مجدين اذا سمحت
غرفه العمليات بس فقط
الفرق التي هي منتشره بكل احياء المدينه
انتم تعلمونها مرتبطه بكم بالتحكم
والسيطره مباشره على كل الاراضي التركيه
ضمن مظله جنيف التي تراقب غرفه عمليات
مركزيه هيك افهم منك
ساذهب معك الان نخرج من عمل من العمليات
الميدانيه التي تجري في هذا التوقيت الى
عمليات انتشال الجثث خليني اذهب معك الى
الدول مباشره جنرال اذا سمحت سريعا كيف عم
يصير التنسيق الان والدول التي سحبت الجثث
من اول دوله
الدوله عندها اعداد ممكن اكبر في سحبه هي
الدوله الجزائر بحكم الموقع متاعها وتوقيت
الوصول متاعها ثم تلقى الترتيب تاع
الاحصاء حسب الدول بتقوم بانزال الاعداد
متاعها في التطبيق خلينا نذهب الجنرال الى
الدول اذا سمحت مباشره كيف تجري كيف سحبت
الجزائر بعد ذلك الجزائر 109
تشيكاريا صفحه 47 تركيا 47
بلغاريا صفحه 43 فرنسا 42 جزء مصاب
الهند 42 تونس 26 روسيا 25
ماليزيا 21
بولونيا 21 ايطاليا 18 والاردن 16
لحتى نصل برايك جنرال التحكم والسيطره بين
الامم المتحده من جهه وبين تركيا من جهه
وبين كل القيادات التي هي على الارض
برايكم من خلال تجربتكم هل هي ممسوكه يعني
حسب ما شفت الان هذا الذي يجب مكنا محليا
دوليا عالميا اقليميا بكل الغرف العمليات
انت راضي عن هذا العمل بالضبط هو بيصير اي
عمل الا بالتنسيق بين المتحده وصوره
المحليه التركيه نعملوا معا بطلب منهم
الاولويات في تحديد الانقاذ والمناطق تطلع
الى السلطه المحليه الي هي السلطه التركيه
ونحن ننفذ سياسه السلطه التركيه اما عبر
منظومه الامم المتحده
محمود عزيزتي يعني رايتي ان تختم هل ممكن
ان تسالوا اذا كان لديهم اي عدد تقديري
حول المواقع التي لم يتم تمشيطها حتى
الساعه
نعم
زميلتي في الاستديو تقول ما هي المواقع
التي لم تنشط يعني المواقع التي لم تذهب
الى اذا سمعت خلينا نذهب الى في اول في
اول الى المواقع الاساسيه الان الان نحن
نتحدث عن 44 الان في مواقع تعمل عليه هل
هنالك من مواقع لم يعمل عليها لكل المواقع
القادمه عليها تم توزيع الفرق القادمه ل
140 فريق على كل المواقع التي تم
مسها الزلزال كل المواقع مشتغله وكل
الاماكن الاماكن اللي تم الوصول اليها نعم
عزيزتي يبدو كما شاهدنا الان هاي الان
خليني اذهب معك الى الصوره مباشره الان هل
هي الان
بهذا التوقيت كما نشاهد اذا سمحت اطلع لي
بس
بالمحافظات يعني شو عم يصير خلينا نطلع من
ادمن الان وين
انطاليا نذهب الى انطاليا نعم
هنالك عدد كبير باي محافظه هذه هيها تايه
اذا الفرق موزعه على كل المحافظات كما
يعني هو معلوم بالمخطط الانقاذي الذي بدات
به الحكومه التركيه بالتنسيق مع المنظمات
والدول التي وصلت الى تركيا ساعود اليك
محمود ابقى معنا من غازي عنتاب مشاهدينا
مفرد العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد
المحسن يعني كنا نرصد معك بالساعات
الماضيه الواقع صعب لكل الناجين كيف
افترشوا الطرقات وكنت يعني تنقل لنا كيف
ان ليس هناك عمليات نصب لخيام من قبل يعني
كامله من قبل منظمات غير حكوميه كيف هو
الواقع الان وما الجديد بالواقع الانساني
من هناك
نعم الجديد في الحقيقه بان كل هذه
الازمات مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه حتى مع
مرور الساعات مع انخفاض درجات الحراره
تزداد المعاناه لدى كثيرين ممن افترشوا
الطرقات ووجدوا خيم غير مؤهله او خيم
صغيره جدا فبالتالي ازمتهم ومعاناتهم
مستمره هنا في غازي عنتاب في مختلف
المناطق ومن افترش الطرقات ومن
بقوا في سياراتهم ومن ايضا ينتظرون مصير
منازلهم هنالك اكثر من تقريبا عشرين
بالبيئه نتحدث عن مليون
مواطن تركي او ايا من الجنسيات المختلفه
سواء كان من السوريين او غيرهم ينتظرون
مصير منازلهم التي تركوها في بعد هذا
الزلزال وهم منتشرون في هذه الشوارع التي
بدات بالعوده تدريجيا الى الحياه اليوم
بشكل بسيط جدا ولكن بعض رغم ان كل المحال
كانت مغلقه الا من استثناءات بسيطه الا ان
البعض عاود بافتتاح منازله او محلاته
وايضا انتشر العديد من
النازحين في اماكن متفرقه في الحدائق في
الملاعب كره القدم في الكنائس في المساجد
ليحتموا من هذا البرد القارص وليجدوا
مكانا يسكن فيه حتى تنتهي هذه المشكله وفي
الحقيقه لا يوجد سالتهم بكم يتوقعون الوقت
اللازم او المتوقع حتى عودتهم الى وضعهم
الطبيعي قالوا بان ليس لديهم ايه معلومات
ربما يستغرق الموضوع اسابيع
طبيعي يعني في حاله ترقب ما زلنا يعني
بحاله ترقب دائمه عدم وضوح للرؤيه بظل
الدمار الهائل الذي حل بهذه المناطق شكرا
لكما مراسلي العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي من
غازي عنتاب ومحمود شكر من اديمان على هذه
الرسائل
جيد او سيء كل ما نملكه كان هنا حتى
اطفالي يبكون ويقولون امي لقد ذهب كل شيء
وذهب الطفولتنا وذكرياتنا معظم متجري ما
كانوا عملي كل شيء دمر بيتي دمر كان لدي
مستودع واحد قد اختفى الان ليس لدي اي شيء
ذهب كل شيء واصبحنا في الشارع
لم يكن مثل اي زلزال اخر دمرت الطرق ودمرت
منازلنا ولم يتبقى اي مبنى اختفى كل شيء
لا احد يعرف كيف سنعيش
الجو بارد وسنتجمد هنا حتى الموت اذا
جلسنا داخل الخيمه فسوف نتجمد
حجاره متراكمه شكلت كوابيس متلاحقه لسبعه
ايام لكنها اسوار اخفت وراءها مخاوف اكبر
تتمثل بطبيعه الخطوه التاليه
السوريون واتراك وضربوا على انتظار مؤلم
رغم فقدان الامل واخرون بداوا لملمه ماسي
الكارثه والخروج من مرحله الانكار لا
منازل لا اعمال لا مقتنياتنا والاقصى
افراد عائله اقل
معظم مجري ما كانوا عملي كل شيء دمر صحوه
من هول الفاجعه اثارت مخاوف مئات الالاف
من التجمد بردا في العراء درجات حراره
شديده الانخفاض لا ترضعها خيم قماشيه او
ثياب خفيفه كما لا تحمي اطفالا من نزله
برد مسكنه الجو بارد وسنتجمد هنا حتى
الموت اذا جلسنا داخل الخيمه فسوف نتجمد
ياتي ذلك وسط تحذيره متزايده من كارثه
ثانيه اكثر ضررا من سابقتها تنبع من تاخر
وصول فرق الطوارئ والمساعدات لملايين
المشردين فالالاف ينامون في سياراتهم قرب
الانقاض
كانوا في العراء بظروف متدهوره ومروعه مع
صعوبه كبيره في الوصول للوقود والمياه
والكهرباء وامدادات الاتصالات
منازل مؤقته او فنادق خطه الحكومه التركيه
لاواء الاشخاص الذين دمرت منازلهم او من
يخافون العوده لابنيه صامده بشقوقها
ومهدده بالسقوط
فالرئيس التركي تعهد بعدم السماح ببقاء
المواطنين في الشارع واعاده بناء مئات
الالاف من المباني بسرعه وان كانت تعهدات
بعيده المنال على حد وصف الكثيرين لكن حتى
هكذا وعوده لم تدس عتبه السوريين اكثر من
خمسه ملايين شخص يضافون الى اعداد مماثله
بعثرتهم الحرب خلال السنوات الاثنتي عشره
الماضيه هؤلاء سيتشاركون نقص المعونات
وظروف السكن الصعبه وبروده الطقس
وفي وقت يتواصل تمشيط اكوام الانقاذ
الشاهقه بحثا عن نفس او صوت يطفئ قلوبنا
ترتجف حسره وبردا يفضل ناجون العوده
لمنازلهم المتضرره بشكل بالغ لحفظ كرامه
اب لا يريد لاطفاله امراضا او امراه
انهكها موت معيل
للحديث اكثر عن الواقع النفسي
من هذا الزلزال
موجود تحت الركان تنضم الينا من بيروت
الاستشاريه النفسيه والاجتماعيه ميسون
حمزه ميسون قبل ان نتحدث عن الحاله
النفسيه لمن نجا من هذا الزلزال سابدا بما
اننا حتى اليوم الثامن مازال هناك حالات
يعني حتى هذه الساعه هناك اناس على قيد
الحياه الحاله النفسيه لمن هو تحت الركاب
من المعلوم اذا تدهورت حالته النفسيه تؤثر
على الوظائف الحيويه مما يؤثر ايضا على
القدره على الاستمرار والعيش تحت الاوقات
كيف يمكن تفسير يعني من استطاعوا الصمود
حتى هذه الساعه
نعم مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين حقيقه
ان من يكون في هذه الحاله ايضا على
المستوى النفسي نستطيع ان نلحظ
ان الجهاز الناس لهؤلاء الافراد قادر على
ان يتصدى في لحظه ما عندما يكون معلق
بالامل يعني تتصدق كل دفعته او اجهزه
دفاعاته النفسيه عندما يكون هنالك خطر
يداهمه وهو محصور في مكان ما
فيدافع بقدر الامكان كي يبقى على قيد
الحياه فالانسان بطبعه مفطور على البقاء
والاستمرار وهو يصارع وينازع من اجل هذا
البقاء في هذه الحاله طبعا هو في حاله قلق
في حاله حذر في حاله ترقب وفي حاله خوف
شديد لانه محاصر ولانه لا يعرف اذا كان
سيستمر او يخرج مما هو فيه ولكن الجهاز
قادر على التصدي
لفتره زمنيه معينه الى ان يفقد يفقد قواه
فعليا مع انقطاع الغذاء او انقطاع الماء
عنه لفتره زمنيه معينه
وهذا
الامل يساعد على النجاه وفقدان الامل
والياس يعني ممكن ان ينهي الحياه اسرع
خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن ظروف طبيعيه صعبه بظل
يعني البرد القارص الموجود وايضا بظل عدم
توفر سبل الحياه هل يمكن تفسير لماذا صمد
العديد من الاطفال اتحدث عن اطفال رضع
اطفال بعمر صغير جدا استطاعوا الصمود
لاسبوع او اكثر تحت الالقاب
حقيقه على مستوى النفسي لا يمكن لنا ان
نتكلم او نتكلم حول هذا الامر ولكن ايضا
الاطفال لديهم قدره على
الاستمرار ويستطيع طبيب ان يفسر لنا
بيولوجيا هذا الامر باستثناء الطفل الذي
كان مازال معلقا يعني حديث الولاده ومعلقا
بحبل الخلاص مع والدته كان يستمد ذلك
الغذاء اما
البقيه لا استطيع ان افسر نفسيا كيفيه
تصديهم لذلك الامر كون اعمارهم لم تتخطى
الايام او لم تتخطى الاشهر ولكن ايضا
استاذ الاطفال
على قيد الحياه هو بحاجه اليوم يعني لدعم
كبير لانهم اذا صح التعبيرهم يعانون بعد
هذا الزلزال ما المطلوب كيف يمكن للمنظمات
غير الحكوميه
الحكومات ان تساعد ايضا للافراد ان
يساعدوا هؤلاء على تخطي هذه الازمه
اولا ما يصاب به اليوم هؤلاء الاشخاص هو
اثار ما بعد الصدمه وهي تداعيات متوقعه
على المستوى النفسي تبدا الاهتمام يبدا
عامل الاهتمام بهم من خلال محاولات
التهدئه والاحتضان من اجل استعاده مشاعر
الامان والتخلص من الخوف ولكن المتابعه
النفسيه يجب ان تتم على مراحل ولفتره
زمنيه طويله من اجل مساعده هؤلاء الافراد
على استخراج مشاعرهم والبوح بها
تخطيها الى ان يعود روتين الحياه
بالمتابعه النفسيه شيئا فشيئا ولكن من
الخطا ان هذا التخطي سيتم بوقت سريع لان
هؤلاء الاشخاص هم لن تتمثل لديهم الصدمه
فقط وانما تمثلت لديهم خسارات على المستوى
الحياتي يعني فقدوا بيوتهم منازلهم وايضا
فقدوا بعض افراد اسرهم لذلك
التدخل العلاجي سيكون طويل
لمعالجه هذه التشوهات والتقلبات التي ممكن
ان يحدث هذه الازمه النفسيه شكرا لك من
بيروت حدثنا الاستشاريه النفسيه
والاجتماعيه ميسون حمزه
لكن
اشتكى مدير مستشفى جبله السوريه من عدم
القدره على اجراء عمليات لمصابين الزلزال
المصابين بكسور عظميه بعد خروج جهاز
التشخيص العظمي عن الخدمه بسبب وقوع
اسطوانات الاكسجين عليها
نتيجه الزلزال القوي في اسطوانات كانت
ارتطمت بجهاز تنظير الجراحي وبجهاز
التنظير القوسي وخرجوا خارج الخدمه مباشره
وهذول الاجهزه كتير الاجهزه ضروريه خاصه
بالحالات الاسعافيه والكوارث ما بتصير اي
عمليه عظميه بدون هالجهاز التنظير القوسي
يجد سكان مدينه جبله الساحليه انفسهم
يتقاسمون الحزن والدمار مع بعد الدمار
الذي خلفه الزلزال في وقت تحاول فيها فرق
الانقاذ في العثور على مزيد من الناجي
[موسيقى]
معنى عضو اداره الدفاع المدني احمد يازج
استاذ احمد سابدا يعني كنت سالت عن هذا
الموضوع قبل وكان الجواب بان تمشيط كل
المدن يعني بهذا العاجل الذي ورد الان
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان يقول بان 21
قريه في مناطق النظام لم تدخلها اي فرق
انقاذ ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني ان فرق الدفاع المدني المتواجده هناك
يوجد على الماء في عمليه التنظيم في عمليه
انتشار هذه الفراق لا يوجد لديهم على ما
اظن الخبرات الكافيه لكي يقوموا بهاكذا
اعمال فرق الدفاع المدني المتواجده في
شمال غرب سوريا عفوا
عن اليوم الاول بعد الاسبوع ولم يدخل احد
الى 21 بلده يعني هذا ليس سوء تنظيم هذه
كارثه تنظيميه نتحدث عن كارثه انسانيه
بهذه المناطق
بالطبع كما كان معلوم سابقا ان فرق
الانقاذ التي تعمل عند
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام هي
فرق غير مدربه وغير مؤهله ويوجد هنالك
تسيب ويوجد ايضا بعض الامور التنظيميه
ولكن هذا كله يتعلق
بالتنظيم والاداره والى الروح التي يعمل
بها الفريق فكان هنالك فرق بين طرق الدفاع
المدني في شمال غرب سوريا التي عملت منذ
اللحظات الاولى على الاستجابه الفوريه
الزلزال عملت على
[موسيقى]
استغفار جميع العناصر هنالك كان نشر حاله
طوارئ في جميع بوادر الدفاع المدني التي
كان يبلغ عددها 2500 شخص بالاضافه كان
هنالك ايضا نداء قبل النداء الى مجتمع
الامم للمجتمع الدولي والامم المتحده كان
نداء الى المجتمع المدني لكي يكون هنالك
تكاثر ايضا ان كان على المستوى الفردي او
على مستوى الاليات التي يمتلكونها فللعلم
كان هناك حتى ايضا بعض المشاريع غياب
مركزيه الدوله انتم يعني استجبتم من مبدا
اللامركزيه التي يعني اصلا انتم معتادون
عليها بظل كل الازمه الماضيه واتحدثون عن
الحرب وسنوات الحرب استاذ احمد هناك سؤال
اساسي يعني هناك تقديرات مختلفه بمناطق
النظام بالمرصاد السوري عند كل فريق هناك
تقديرات مختلفه عند الدفاع المدني اليوم
هل هناك من تقديرات مبدئيه حول عدد
المفقودين بناء على البلاغات التي وصلتكم
او نداءات الاستغاثه التي وصلتكم
بالنسبه للتقديرات التي يطلقها الدفاع
المدني نحن نطلق ارقام قام الدفاع المدني
بانتسالها او بعمليات الانقاذ في حال نحن
نقول ان هنالك 2169 شخص
فقدوا حياتهم او بالاضافه الى 2950
عملت فرق الانقاذ على انتشالهم احياء من
تحت الانقاض فهذا الرقم هو الدفاع المدني
من قام به ليس ارقام خياليه هي موثقه
بالاسماء موثقه بالاشخاص يوجد لدينا كافه
البيانات عن هؤلاء الاطفال لا يوجد لدينا
مبالغه بالارقام ولكن هناك سوف يكون
تقارب مع مديريه انا انا ما سالت عنه
المفقودين هل لديكم اعداد عن المفقودين من
لم يتم العثور عنهم بناء على البلاغات
التي تلقيتموها
يمكننا الان ان نقول من
البيانات المتواجده بين يدينا انه الى حد
هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي مفقود تحت الانقاذ
في شمال غرب سوريا كامله
هذه مبالغه يعني هل انتهت عمليات الانقاذ
هل تم يعني ازاحه جميع الردم هل تم انتشال
كل الجثث لا بحسب المراسل هناك لم تنتهي
هي ليست من مبالغه وهي ليست من وحي الخيال
الفرق لم تهدا الى حد هذه اللحظه انتهت
عمليات الانقاذ في شمال سوريا
متواجده في اماكن العمل لم تقوم باخلاء
النقاط التي كانت تعمل بها الى حد هذه
اللحظه ولكن نحن نعمل على بيانات مقدمه من
قبل الاهالي عن وجود ضحايا تحت الانقاض او
عن وجود مفقودين عملنا خلال اليومين
الماضيين منذ اعلاننا عن الانتقال الى
عمليه الانتشار عملنا في الوقت
المثابره ليلا ونهارا على عمليه اخراج
هؤلاء المفقودين ولكن اليوم
يعني انت تقول لا يوجد وبالتالي انتهيتم
من عمليه الانقاذ وانتشال الضحايا جواب
على هذا السؤال لو سمحت
تماما انا قلت حسب المعطيات الان التي
وردتنا من قبل المدنيين الان لا يوجد احد
تحت الانقاض في شمال غرب سوريا
سنبقى نتابع التقارير التاليه الوارده من
شمال سوريا شكرا لك احمد يزن عضو اداره
الدفاع المدني
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان انه من المهم جدا تامين وصول
المساعدات الى مستحقيها في مناطق تركيا
ومناطق سوريا كافه
الكارثه التي حلت بكل من تركيا وسوريا
كبيره جدا وتقتضي توفير المساعدات
المناسبه المملكه ردت على الكارثه من خلال
ارسال المساعدات وفرق الاغاثه الى كلا
البلدين ونشجع الجميع على تقديم المساعدات
وفق ما تم بحثه في الاجتماع الثنائي مع
المندوب السامي السيد مرعب ومن المهم جدا
تامين وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها في
تركيا وسوريا كافه يجب العمل على تخفيف
معاناه الشعب السوري ونبذر ما بوسعنا من
اجل وصول المساعدات الى المناطق كافه في
الداخل السوري
طبعا بدايه بحب اذكر انه اول شيء الطائرات
دخلت من خلال معبر جوي اغاثه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا هاي
الطائرات دخل منها الى سوريا قافيه واحده
اللي هي عباره عن 11 شحنه بقيه الحملات
راح يتم توزيعها بين سوريا وبتركيا
بالنسبه للجانب السوري فاللي دخل هو عباره
عن ايداع الشاحنه من خلال معبر الحمام مع
تركيا هاي الشواحين تتضمن عده مواد اللي
هي مواد غذائيه خلال غذائيه ومواد غير
غذائيه اللي هي طبعا كانت عباره عن خيم
وسلال واغطيه
للناس اللي ضررت يؤثر الزلزال اللي صار
الجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا طبعا هاي المواد
تتم توزيعها بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين
احنا حاليا متواجدين بوسط من ناحيه جنديرس
عم نقوم ببناء واحد المخيمات طبعا هذا
المخيم رقم ثلاثه اللي احنا عم نباشر فيه
ان شاء الله وغدا الفرق راح تكون متواجده
بمناطق ادلب ان شاء الله رب العالمين
حنحاول نوصل لاكبر عدد ممكن من خلال
الفتره القادمه
[موسيقى]